Film Courage: When did the idea for Passionflix
begin?
Passionflix Co-Founder and CEO, Tosca Musk:
The idea for Passionflix came about…it was
actually Joany’s idea.
Joany Kane is our founding partner.
She had the idea quite a few years ago.
When FIFTY SHADES OF GREY came out, she was
wondering why there isn’t a place for romance
novels that had been turned into movies when
the movie was such a success.
So she actually got the URL (passionflix.com)
and said “I’m going to do this.”
And then many years later nothing happened
to it.
Until one New Year’s Eve she decided ‘I’m
going to make it happen’ and she booked
a flight to Los Angeles.
And it just so happens that Joany and I had
met a few months prior.
She had watched a movie of mine on Aeon [Network]
called YOU CAST A SPELL ON ME.
And she contacted me the next day and said
“I absolutely loved your movie.
I loved how you directed that movie and I
would really love it if you would take one
of my movies and direct that.”
And normally you get a lot of people that
solicit you and normally you’re like “No,
I’m going to ignore that.”
But her note was so sweet and she was just
so open in her communication to me that I
was like “Okay, let me have a look at the
script.”
And I was like “Oh!
She can really write.
She’s a good writer.
So let’s meet.”
We tried to bring that movie to a network
but no one would buy it because it was a little
too sensual, it was a little to risqué, and
it had to do with magick and that doesn’t
really work well with network television.
So that didn’t work.
But when she came over that February, we say
down and had lunch with her other partner
Jina [Panebianco].
And over tunafish sandwiches she told us this
thought that she had of Passionflix and we
said “Great!
It’s a great idea.”
And we literally started the next day on basically
creating the company, the business plan, put
together a full proposal and think about how
are we going to do all of this.
But then I spent the next few months raising
money and it took about a year to raise the
money and then optioned books and made our
first feature last March.
Long answer!
Film Courage: That’s interesting, so you
had never really known Joany (and that’s
her name, right?) previously it was just that
initial email and you just kind of went on
a gut feeling that “Wow!
This is someone I want to work with.”
Tosca Musk: So the answer is yes.
I didn’t know Joany very well at all except
for the communication we had on the one screenplay
that she’d written and that screenplay was
good.
And as a director when you get to work with
a screenwriter and they are open to your comments
and your notes and they adjust their screenplay
according to how you see it as a filmmaker,
that collaboration just forms a deep partnership
to begin with.
So I didn’t know her personally.
I’d never met her in person until February
but we’d work together by email and phone
calls for a few months prior to that.
And so as a filmmaker, I knew her well.
Film Courage: Okay so then you raised was
it 4.7 million in seed funding?
Tosca Musk: 4.75.
Film Courage: 4.75!
Okay.
Tosca Musk: 4,753,000.
Film Courage: Good to know.
Can you briefly tell us how this happened?
Did you have specific people in mind you knew
you wanted to approach?
Tosca Musk: So that was the difficult part.
Firstly, I’m related to a lot of people
that have raised a lot of people (which is
helpful).
And so I went to them for advice.
What do I do, who do you approach?
And they basically said “Everybody.”
You just go to anybody.
You just constantly tell what the idea is
to every single person that you meet and somebody
is going to say “Hey, I have somebody who
is going to be interested in that.”
And that’s what happened.
I literally just went to every single person
that I knew that had any ability to invest
and “I said this is the idea, this is what
I’d like to do, do you have any advice for
me and would you be interested in coming on
board?”
And some people came on board with $5,000,
some people came on board with $50,000.
So they weren’t huge amounts, but everybody
that I spoke to wanted to participate because
they think they idea is really good.
Film Courage: I’m always wondering how that
happens?
Is it a long email?
Is it a phone call?
Is it when you see them at an event?
Tosca Musk: It’s all of those things.
I will take the opportunity to tell people
about Passionflix every single place that
I go.
So it will be at a coffeeshop when I’m wearing
a Passionflix t-shirt and I will tell the
people there.
It will be at a lunch, it will be at an event.
I don’t send long emails because most of
the people you are dealing with don’t have
time to read long emails and they’ll ignore
them.
So short and to the point with very specific
information in it and what you want.
What it is that you are looking to do, what
it is that you want and I’m happy to provide
you with any further supportive documents
for you to review this.
That was basically what I do.
I’m about to do it again because we need
to do another raise.
Film Courage: Is this similar to raising money
for a film?
Or are they two separate animals?
Tosca Musk: Raising money for a film, it is
different.
Because here I’m raising money for a company
that is a distribution company that has an
overall goal, which is to empower women through
emotional strength while at the same time
owns multiple movies.
So we are not making one movie, we are making
50.
If you invest in Passionflix you get a part
of all 50 movies that we own forever.
Should the company not do well as a distribution
company, you still have all these assets and
you’re able to sell them and hopefully we’ll
make that $50,000 back (I’m sure we will).
That’s why it’s not a difficult ask when
it comes to investment because when you’re
looking for an investment in one single picture,
it’s basically saying “Hi, I have a movie
I want to make.
I’m going to spend 3 million dollars on
this movie.
Can you give me some money?
And hopefully everybody else likes this movie
and I can get a distributor and I can get
it into the theaters or get it into DVD or
some foreign market.
Hopefully we’ll make our money back and
then you can get your 20%.”
That’s the individual filmmaking side.
Which is a different beast and there are a
lot of people that want to invest that way,
specifically in California or in the U.S.
What I mean is there are tax write-offs that
are involved, there’s all these different
things that are positive for investors to
invest in individual films, but that’s not
what we’re looking for.